and finally new rule black people have
to demand that white people stop
culturally appropriating how mad they
are about racism it's great that
Caucasians have finally joined the fight
for racial justice and unprecedented
numbers but hating racism the most you
can't steal that Elvis taking little
Richards act that was bad enough
Victor Tseng B is an Oakland resident
who put up small loops for footholds on
trees in a local park for exercise and
games he says out of the dozens and
hundreds and thousands of people that
have walked by no one you know has
thought that it looked anywhere close to
a news but Oakland's mayor Libby Schaaf
wasn't gonna let all that cheat her out
of a chance to signal her virtue she
said these incidents will be
investigated as a hate crime why is this
white woman seeing racism where a black
man isn't the mayor also said intentions
don't matter but they do matter and
white people need to stop trying to
cancel other white people whose heart is
in the right place but don't get it
exactly right on the first try
a few weeks ago when everyone was
posting a black square on Instagram
BuzzFeed wrote influencers it's a
privilege to post a black square and
then go back to your usual content as
opposed to what abandoning your life and
just posting a black square every day
people got called out for not posting
the square then for just posting it
without speaking out and then for
posting it and speaking out but not
voicing their support in the exact way
that was said in the new decoder ring
they were helping wrong Ellen DeGeneres
felt enough pressure so that she erased
a tweet that said people of color in
this country have faced injustice for
far too long okay that may not be
exactly black lives matter but it's also
very true and pretty close to what we're
trying to get everyone to understand
liberalism should be about lifting
people up and you don't do that by
slapping down P
who are trying to say I'm on your side
no wonder white people right now we're
acting like a nervous waiter on their
first day so scared of making a mistake
they put a fork in your iced tea and a
straw in your salad we don't want to
chant the wrong chant or hold the wrong
sign hey please it's all we can do to
clap on the right beat you want to be a
good Ally but not too good or you're
being a white Savior use your voice but
don't make it about yourself but speak
up unless it's your time to just listen
and then silence is violence hey even
though sometimes silence just means
someone works two jobs and has three
kids they have baby food on their shirt
not hate in their heart some guy just
wrote into the New York Post I am a
senior level leader in an organization
and feel compelled to speak up about
racial injustice but I'm afraid to as a
white man I'm afraid that I will say
something that will be misinterpreted
and I will do more harm than good
for my career two things silence seems
wrong but safer am I alone in this
unfortunately no there was a sports
announcer in Sacramento who tweeted all
lives matter and immediately got fired
even though he apologized and said he
just didn't understand what he said came
from a place of ignorance not racism
that difference is important
someone could have just explained to him
why there's a deservedly special reason
we single out black lives for protection
but now instead of a possible ally we
create a bitter unemployed person Willow
Smith yes Willow Smith said I'm seeing
people shaming others for what they are
choosing to say or shaming people for
not saying anything at all I feel like
if we really want change shaming doesn't
lead to learning she gets it surely
people twice her age could make the
effort I worry that the kind of tension
that the guardians of gotcha are
creating is going to make people afraid
to mingle at all and thrust us back
towards a resegregate of sorts we're
instead of just seeing a purse
and not a color now we're only seeing
color maybe this is old school
liberalism talking but I don't think
that's the way to go let's hang out and
if I [ __ ] up tell me why not goodbye
it's a gradual years long process like
Trump descending a ramp but things are
better when the races get together like
when rappers sample Steely Dan
you